hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to
another edition of ask Evan in today's
episode I'm going to answer a question
from one of my newsletter readers Han
who's a lawyer and is trying to grow her
40 base for her practice and also be
seen as an expert and get some leads
pretentious the media and one of my
advice on what to do sohan the most
important thing I can see for lawyers
and I've seen a lot of lawyers grow
their practice is to get referrals from
other lawyers and the reason why it's
important I think especially for lawyers
is other lawyers can really give you
ideal clients so it's hard for the
general public to kind of give you
clients because they know your lawyer
but they may not know exactly what you
do are the types of cases that you work
on and the ideal clients so say oh yeah
I have a friend is looking for Lori oh
they'll give you the name but it's not
the type of law you do and they may not
have a budget and all these kinds of
things so it's really hard to get
referrals from general public the great
thing about of the lawyers is that they
can clearly understand what type of work
you do they know that you know the size
of client that you work with they can
give you people who have the budget to
hire you and it's really the best source
of finding business through referrals is
to get those other lawyers on board so
what I would do is in trying to grow my
marketing plan to talk to other lawyers
and get them to know who you are at
least once a week try to set up a coffee
or lunch or dinner or event with another
lawyer who might be a potential referral
source for you and you know you can also
send business to them as well so it's
getting that kind of relationship going
where you know about their business they
know about you and you can start
potentially funneling business to each
other so at least once a week try to set
up one of those meetings to get to know
some new people on top of that I'd also
look at some of who your key connectors
are so who has referred business to you
in the past who do you think it could be
ongoing sources and at least once a
quarter try to keep that contact going
so again if it's coffee or lunch or
dinner if you're even just sending them
gifts but will do is send brownies to
some of our key influencers once a
quarter so think about how you can just
stay top of mind you want a reason to
connect with them at least once a
quarter I need to be
we already have a relationship with so
once a week try to get new relationships
going and then once a quarter try to
manage those existing relationships the
ones that are giving you some fruit and
giving you some leads so it's still I
think going to be your bride and body
you're going to get your best leads from
neutrinos relationships with other
lawyers if you want to go up to the
media that couldn't hurt there's a
couple ways to do we've had some good
success getting into the media the first
thing I would do is try to build your
own list so look at your local area see
who's covering legal issues and you know
reporters are always looking for experts
to come on and talk about the issues so
you you know you could be that legal
expert why couldn't you be that expert
for the area of law that you cover the
second thing I would do is look at
google news alerts so for whatever you
know law area you cover you can enter in
certain keywords and anytime there's a
story that comes up you can be notified
and you can write to the reporter
introduce yourself establish a
relationship talk about your point of
view what you have to say and the next
time one of those stories comes along
they might call on you to be that expert
and the third one that I would look at
is PR leads and that's a paid service
google news is free the PR leads is
basically service where reporters will
submit their story ideas and they're
looking for experts so you know the
stories coming up you know they have a
deadline and you're looking for experts
to come on and talk about you know
whatever that idea is so that could be a
great opportunity to again introduce
yourself to those reporters and get
covered in the media so I've used PR
elite successfully we've gotten into New
York Times Forbes other big-name
publications so i know it works but
there is a fee to it it's usually 100
bucks a month so hopefully that helps
i'd still focusing on that referral
network get those lawyers coming in but
going after media strategy could also
help and hopefully those strategies are
helpful for you hon so if you guys like
the video thank you for tuning in I'd
love to see those thumbs ups if you can
leave one under the video and I'd also
love to hear what you have to think if
you want to leave a comment below and
stay tuned for next episode
you